[Music]
vente leaders have emerged as a crucial
weapon in hospital coronavirus treatment
they move air in and out of the lungs
for critically ill patients whose
infections have made it impossible to
breathe on their own but hospitals
around the world are struggling with
ventilator shortages and manufacturing
efforts aren't moving fast enough to
meet the rising need this has spurred a
number of engineers universities and
medical professionals into action for
several weeks they've been gathering in
facebook groups slack channels and
websites to share expertise ideas and
designs for homemade ventilators and
then it goes into one of these valves
here which controls inflating these bags
at the back but will any of these
open-source plans ever turn into real
ventilators that actually help save
lives
MIT recently launched this website to
resurface a 10 year old project to
automate a hand pump the ventilator also
known as a manual resuscitator in 2010
they published a paper detailing their
design and testing now a group of
engineers and medical professionals in
Colombia are using mi t--'s plans in an
effort to mass-produce emergency
ventilators in meta-gene the idea is try
to get some machines together they can
make at across about a thousand $1,300
something like that and this is a
machine that's actually far simpler than
the machines that you might find say in
a hospital right now in public dollar
New York or in Mexico City because it
can cost thirty thirty five thousand
twenty five thousand dollars these are
definitely sort of emergency machines
the current unprecedented global demand
has made importing ventilators or even
their parts difficult everywhere and
virtually impossible in developing
countries like Colombia in speed ahmed
has partnered with a number of domestic
automotive and home appliance
manufacturers to build locally they're
also working with Columbia's version of
the FDA called env MA
to make sure their devices meet all of
the country's federal safety standards
they're having discussions with them
they have an attorney paperwork and get
approval for the next step to test these
prototypes on human beings and if that
works well
then they will be given the approval to
produce these in the factory's amenity
in spit amid hopes an Vemma approval
moves quickly enough to have 1500
machines manufactured and operating in
hospitals by May when epidemiologists
predict Columbia will hit the peak of
coronavirus infections in other parts of
the world
another group of medical professionals
academics and engineers recently
published a different proof of concept
for an emergency ventilator that can be
built without the help of local
manufacturers or factories we sit with
the doctors in the beginning and say
okay give us the medical minimum that
ventilator needs to achieve and we'll
strip down and try to design a machine
that was so simple that you can build it
everywhere in the world this is a
last-resort machine unregulated and more
widely available materials mean an even
more accessible ventilator but there are
risks that come with using parts like
construction materials in a medical
setting regulations for medical
equipment are much more stringent than
for commercial hardware just the level
of testing the level of reliability
redundancy duration of use the duty
cycle on in how long things are expected
to perform they're different for
different settings dr. Pankaj Murcia
worries that some of these open source
ventilator systems could fail in
practice even after successful tests
with a prototype would you're turning on
and off your garden sprinklers or your
lawn sprinkler once a week they just
aren't designed to do this 20,000 times
a day without missing a breath dr. Lou
Chia is working on developing adapters
to repurpose CPAP machines as
ventilators CPAP machines which are much
less expensive and more common than
ventilators help patients with sleep
apnea I maintain a steady breathing
pattern throughout the night they're
about 60 million Americans who have
sleep apnea and there's over a million
of these machines currently in the
United States we're converting the BiPAP
machines New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
recently announced State Department
Health approval and plans to convert
BiPAP machines which are similar to
see pops into ventilators and while this
kind of solution makes sense for places
like the u.s. it doesn't help solve
shortage problems in areas lacking these
sleep aid devices if you have nothing
available and you're in a battlefield
and someone gets shot by a bullet
instead of using a preformed tourniquet
if you take off your own belt to prevent
them from bleeding out and dying that's
okay
because you have nothing better so
depending upon what's available to you
in the healthcare system where you're
located available in that it's there now
when you need it you have to make the
best choice available